اهلا بكم اتحدث اليوم الى بول بيلار
المساعد السابق لمدير وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه والمسؤول الاول فيها
عن مناطق الشرق الادنى والخليج وجنوب اسيا
لمده 28 عاما سنساله عن النزاع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني وتداعيات تطوراته الاخيره على
المشهد الدولي في ضوء نجاح الصين فيما
فشلت فيه الولايات المتحده وتهدئه توترات
الشرق الاوسط من العربيه احييكم اينما
كنتم انا منتهى الرمحي وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى حتى المعلقون
الاسرائيليون يصفون هذه الايام التي تمر
بها بلادهم بانها غير مسبوقه القضيه
الفلسطينيه عادت الى الواجهه بعد ان تراجع
موقعها في العقد الاخير والامل في مزيد من
اتفاقات السلام في المنطقه بدا يواجهوا
الاسئله تضع دوره العنف الجديده سؤالا حول
ما اذا كانت حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
متوافقه مع السعي لمزيد من التطبيع ولو
انه من المؤكد انه لن يكون هناك عوده الى
الوراء لكن ايضا من غير المرجح ان يكون
هناك تقدم على صعيد السلام في المدى
المنظور على الاقل الازمه ليست اسرائيليه
بحته حيث ان لها عواقب اقليميه تذكر
بماساه قديما زلقت تحت البساط في السنوات
الاخيره لكنها عائده لتؤرق المنطقه الا
وهي القضيه الفلسطينيه
لطالما خفتت تلك القضيه اعلاميا على الاقل
لتترك مكانها لسعي اسرائيلي مع دول عربيه
للتنسيق ضد عدو مشترك يعد اولويه هو ايران
بسبب سياساتها التوسعيه فالاراضي العربيه
الى جانب تقدمها المضطرد نحو سلاح النووي
لكن ضبط النفس ليس من سمات الاحزاب التي
تشكل حكومه الاغلبيه
لنتنياهو الاصوليون المتدينون
والاستيطانيون يعتزمون ضم الضفه الغربيه
ببساطه ضاربين عرض الحائط اتفاقات اسرائيل
السابقه اخر عقبه امام ذلك هي المحكمه
العليا لاسيما ان ممثليهم موجودون الان في
قلب الدوله
كانت النتيجه طبيعيه عنف شبه يومي ذهب فيه
عشرات الفلسطينيين ضحيه كل ذلك يطرح اسئله
امام الوضع الذي عاشته المنطقه في العقد
الاخير لكنها تطورا اخرا بصدد التشكل فقد
دفع الانسحاب الامريكي من المنطقه والثقل
الذي تلعبه الصين فيها اليوم دفع دولها
الى الحوار مع ايران وفي الوقت الذي يضع
هذا التطور اللافت اسئله امام عشريه
الاقتراب من مع الخارج المجاور يلامس
نتنياهو في الداخل ما يشبه حدود الحرب
الاهليه نرحب معا بالسيده بول بيلار
البروفيسور في جامعه جورج تاون والمسؤول
السابق في وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه
اهلا بك معنا في البعد الاخر
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه دعني ابدا معك من
العنف الذي نراه يتجدد في الشرق الاوسط
باعمال عنف بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وايضا حزب الله هل كان هذا متوقعا
كان مفاجا لاي من المراقبين للشرق الاوسط
فسبقه وان كانت هناك منذ اشهر
الزياده في العنف بين اسرائيل
والفلسطينيين 2022 كانت اكثر السنوات عنفا
منذ حوالي عاقدين
بعدد القسم الفلسطينيين على ايدي القوات
الاسرائيليه وكذلك الاسرائيليين على ايدي
الفلسطينيين وعلاوه على ذلك
لدينا
العمل الماضي اكثر حكومه متطرف جناحها
اليمين في تاريخ اسرائيل
وانتسبت في تفاقم الاوضاع ليس فقط خصوص
السياسات هذا النظام بل كذلك كل المخاوف
التي بثتها على الجانب الفلسطيني
هناك حاله جمود في الوضع القائم على في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بين فلسطين واسرائيل
هذا كله يؤدي الى تجدد العنف بسبب او بدون
سبب مهما كان السبب صغير الا يوجد هناك
اليه
لتحريك اي اي شيء في سماء هذه المنطقه من
اجل تغيير هذا الوضع طالما ان العنف متجدد
ومتكرر
عندما كنا نتحدث عن
النزاع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني فنعم
لا توجد اي نتيجه لذلك فما يخص اي حل لهذا
النزاع وعلينا ان نبحث اولا واخرا عن
الوضع الاسرائيلي
واغلب الاسرائيليين بامكانهم ان يعيشوا
فيه حياه طبيعيه
وينسون
خلالهما يجري في الجانب الاخر في جدار
الفاصل مع الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربي
وكذلك في قطاع غزه والى ان يكون هنالك
تغيير اساسي في رغبه الجانب الاسرائيلي
فلا اتوقع اننا سنشهد اي تقدم خاصه وان
الطرف الاساسي الرئيسي الخارجي هو
الولايات المتحده لم تتناء عن سياساتها
الاساسيه لرؤيه نفسه على انها دعم الاكبر
لاسرائيل طيب يعني كان لدى البعض او خلق
امل لدى البعض من ان الامور قد تتحرك
باتجاه ايجابي مع فكره اقامه علاقات
دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل حتى ولو انه معظم
الدول العربيه لم تقم علاقات دبلوماسيه
كامله مع اسرائيل حتى الان اولا لو من
وجهه نظرك لماذا ترى ان دول عربيه لا تقيم
علاقات بشكل كامل وهناك علاقات صارت بين
اسرائيل ودول العربيه الا يعد هذا كافيه
بالنسبه لاسرائيل
اغلب الدول العربيه اللي عن تحقيق علاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع فلسطين هو الاحتلال
المستمر مناطق الفلسطينيه
ومنعها حق المصير الفلسطينيين هذه
التي
رفضها الجامعه الدول العربيه تحت قياده
الملك عبد الله راح الملك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولا تزال هذه سياسه الجامعه
العربيه على رغم ان بعض الدول مثل اماره
العربيه المتحده والمغرب والبحرين تنعت عن
هذه السياسه واما فيما يخص كم يكفي
فالحكومه الاسرائيليه تقيم بشكل كبير
تحسين العلاقات مع تلك الدول التي ذكرتها
انفا ولكن كل الاسرائيليين يرغبون بعلاقات
كامله مع كل دول المنطقه وبهذا الخصوص
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي بلا شك
الجائزه الاكبر بالنسبه لهم ورئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو لو كانت له امنيه واحده وحتى
امنيه زملائه ان المملكه علاقات دون ماسيه
كامله مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهنا اود مره اخرى لسؤالي حول الامل الذي
خلقته لدى البعض اقامه علاقات مع اسرائيل
بان بين دول عربيه واسرائيل بانه قد يحرك
الملف الا تعتقد بانه لم يكن هذا صحيحا من
من كان المستفيد الابرز من اقامه مثل هذه
العلاقات هل واشنطن مثلا مستفيده منها
الاكبر من تحسين تلك العلاقات هو حكومه
اسرائيل والتي ارادت ان تظهر انها يمكن ان
يكون لها علاقات طبيعيه مع
الدول الجوار العربيه من دون حل المشكله
الفلسطينيه
ومن دون تحقيق تقدم وتجاه الدوله
وكما نقول هنا في الولايات المتحده تحصل
على كعكتك وتاكلها انت بالكامل
فهذه خطوه بعيده جدا عن المزيد من السلام
فيما يخص الاوبن اسرائيل وفلسطين
نحيا الاسرائيليه هي الطريقه لتجاوز
الفلسطينيين ولتظهر بانني
من خلال هذه القراءه قلت اهميته من وجهه
نظر على الاقل بعض الحكومات العربيه الى
الحاد الذي يسمعه لهم بكسر اجماع جمع
الدول العربيه لتكون هناك علاقات كامله مع
اسرائيل على الر من عدم تحقيق اي تقدم
تجاه حل النزاع مع الفلسطينيين لذلك
فبعيدا ان اكون حركه السلام فكانت حركه
بعيده عن السلام وليست خاصه بحل السلام
وتحقيق السلام او حل النزاع الفلسطيني ان
اسال عن موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لطالما كانت تقول امريكا بانه قضيه السلام
والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط قضيه مهمه
بالنسبه لها وبالنهايه هي ستكون مستفيده
باي شكل من الاشكال لماذا توقف السعي
الامريكي عن ايجاد
حاله استقرار داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه او
بين الجانبين الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
الامر يتلخصات المحليه داخل الولايات
المتحده نعم وكما ذكرتي
فان السياسه المعلنه
لادارات الامريكيه
المتتاليه كانت لدعم فكره تحقيق الاستقرار
بين الفلسطيني والاسرائيليين ولكن
الولايات المتحده لما تستخدم اي سلطه لها
على اسرائيل ولا حتى تعرف فلسطين ولكن
بشكل خاص على اسرائيل
الدعم الاقتصادي والدبلوماسي المستمر
اعتقد بان الوضع الحالي
اظهر وظهر مؤخرا عندما
حتى رئيس بايدن حكومه نتنهاء على عدم
الاستمرار بخططها لتجاوز
اسرائيل ليست في حاله حرب مع الامارات
العربيه المتحده او المغرب او البحرين او
السودان كل واحد من هذه الدول العربيه سبق
وان جرى من دون العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
الكامله ايضا وهذا يشمل العديد من
الاتصالات بين المسؤولين في حكومه تلك
الدول
ولكن يعني ما الذي يهم اسرائيل في هذه
الحاله ما الذي تركز عليه في مساله سعيها
لاقامه علاقات
مع دول عربيه هل هي علاقات مع دول متكافئه
ام الترويج لفكره تشكيل تحالف مناهض
لايران بدرجه الاولى
هي الاثنين ما ذكرتي او اعتقد ان الغرضين
الاساسيين هو اولا ما ذكرته وحاول اظهار
انهم يستطيعون العلاقات كامله
واهمالي المساله الفلسطينيه وكذلك بنائي
وتعزيز تحالف مبادئ لايران وبلا شكاوي
يمثلان كبيرا من ذلك فالقياده الاسرائيليه
تحدثت بعلنا عن تطوير العلاقات الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه بل حتى الحكومات
السابقه وخاصه كل تلك التي قادتها
انهم هدفان اساسيا لاسرائيل طيب سيدنا
ارجو ان تبقى معنا سنذهب الى فاصل قصير
نعود بعده لمتابعه حوارنا قومانا
[موسيقى]
ارحب بكم معنا من جديد في البعد الاخر كما
ارحب بالسيد بيلار البروفيسور في جامعه
جورج تاون والمسؤول السابق في وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه اعود معك للقضيه
الرئيسيه وهي
ما روج له بان اقامه علاقات مع بعض الدول
العربيه هو لمواجهه اقامه تحالف ضد ايران
في مقال لك تعتبر انه ما كان يتعين على
الولايات المتحده للقيام به فيما يتعلق
بصنع السلام الحقيقي في الخليج والشرق
الاوسط ناجحت فيه الصين واسمح لي ان اقتبس
من مقالك ان ما انجزه الصينيون كان خطوه
تخفيض حقيقي للتوتر من اجل ارساء السلام
كيف تقيم هذا النجاح الصيني وهل تتوقع
المزيد منه
كان خطوه حقيقيه تجاهها تقليل التوترات
ولا شك بان الخصومه والتوترات بين
ايران او المملكه العربيه السعوديه ربما
كانت
المشكله الاساسيه في منطقه الخليج العربي
والمرتبطه بالنزاع المسلح
سواء بشكل غير مباشر خاصه في حرب اليمن
القوه الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه منخرطه فيه والحوتين
بجانب الاخر مدعومون من ايران وكذلك اشكال
مباشره مثل اطلاق الصواريخ والمسارات ضد
مشاه نفط السعوديه في عام 2019
واغلب المراقبين استنتجوا بان ايران
مسؤوله عن ذلك فاذا ما
اذا كان هنالك تحت العلاقاتي بين هاتين
القوه الاساسيتين في جانبي الخليج العربي
فلا شك بان هذه خطوه تجاهك المنطقه اكثر
السلامه واستقرارا اما فيما يخص ما تفعله
الصينيون لاحقا متابعه بعد هذه الخطوه في
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه او دون يشير
الى ان الصيناء استضافات اجتماع الوزراء
خارجيه ايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وناقشها خلال عام التحسين التعاون الواقعي
لاستعاده الخدمات الخطوط الجويه بين
البلدين وكذلك تعزيز خدماتي اشارات الدخول
المسافرين لكي يتحركوا من الدوله الى اخرى
واعتقد بان الصين ستستمر بدعم تطبيق
هذه المتابعه على استعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وكما اود ان اضيف بيانات
اطراف الثالثه مفيده كانت مشاركه مثل
العمانيون
وبدا بانهم كانوا واسطنطا في دين جدا ثم
يخص التقدم الاخير لنهائي الحرب في اليمن
هل
الصين تتقدم في المنطقه على حساب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او بسبب تراجع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ام كيف سيكون الحال
بوجود الصين وامريكا في المنطقه
لان لديها علاقات مع الجميع في المنطقات
تماما كما لديها مع كافه المناطق العالم
ولا تحاول ان تقسم العالم الى اصدقاء
واعداء ونتحدث فقط عن الاصدقاء
تتجاهل ولا دعوه كان هذا هو الاساس
الدبلوم
شاهدناه لتحقيق العلاقه تحسينها بين ايران
والسعوديه الولايات المتحده كانت تفعل نفس
الشيء اذا ما اتبعت سياسه مشابهه لعدم
تقسيم العالم الى اصدقاء واعداء والتحدث
مع الجميع ولكن سياسه امريكا كانت غير ذلك
هنا في الشرق الاوسط لا يوجد اي حوار او
حديث ما عدا على مسارات ضيقه مثلا مع
ايران ولا تجد اي محادثات مع النظام
السوري في دمشق
وبالتالي فان الولايات المتحده لم تضع
نفسها في موقف لتحقيق مثل هذه الانجازات
لو وسعت مقاربتها
الصين وحتى مقاربه روسيا للشرق الاوسط
لانها تتحدث مع الجميع من اسرائيل الى
ايران فالولايات المتحده كان يمكن ان تكون
مفيده جدا للاستقرار الشرق الاوسط لدينا
موقفها يمنع ذلك حاليا طيب يعني لو اردنا
ان نصف موقع الصين الان حاليا بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي العلاقه
بالحرب البارده اين هو اين تضعه
الصين الان بلا ادنى شك قوه كبرى او كل
هذا يعود الى اواخر السبعينات القرن
الماضي عندما قام دانشون بفتح الاقتصاد
الصيني مما قادر
الى هذا النمو الاقتصاديه الكبير جدا عبر
العقود الماضيه مما سمح لصيني يمارس سيتي
ثقلها عسكريا ودبلوماسيا ايضا
موقفه حينها وهو لنحافظ على الهدوء ونعز
قواتنا والان حصل وصلوا الى هذه القوه الى
الحد الذي تستطيع ان تقوم فيه اسهامات
ايجابيه مثل مجال تحدثنا عنه وتخفيض
التوترات في الخليج العربي من اجل مصلحه
الجميع هنالك مناطق اخرى خاصه في شرق
الهادئ حيث الولايات المتحده والصين
بالتحديد لديهما خلافات وهنالك احتمال
لخروج التوترات عن الطاقه السيطره وهذا
يقلقنا جميعا ولكن حقيقه وصول الصين على
انها من القوى الكبرى في العالم اصولها
لهذه المرحله اتمنى ان تساهم بايجابيه
اكثر من السلبيه
كما نجحت الصين على الاقل حتى الان في
منطقه الخليج الخليج العربي وفي ما يتعلق
بايران والامل بانهاء الاحداث في اليمن هل
يمكن للصين ان يكون لها دور على صعيد
الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي ام ان هذا
الملف ملف امريكي بحث لا يمكن لاحد التدخل
به او او مساعده اي طرف على المضي قدما
نحو
خطوه ايجابيه
اعتقد بان الصينيين بكل حذار سيختارون
الحالات او الاوضاع التي يدخلون فيها ولن
يبذلوا جهود الدبلوماسيه لا يرون فيها
املا كبيرا بالنجاح ولا اعتقد انهم يرون
املا كبيرا من النجاح عندما ارادوا التدخل
بشكل مباشر في النزاع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني فسوف يستنتجون كما استنتج
الكثيرون بين الطرف الخارجي الاساسي ولا
الولايات المتحده نظرا للعلاقات القويه
جدا بين امريكا واسرائيل لذلك اشك بان
الصينيين سيحاولون تداخل في هذا النزاع
حتى روسيا يعني هي تتدخل احيانا وتتوقف
احيانا كثيره في هذا الموضوع وبالحديث عن
روسيا انت تعتبر ان اي حرب بارده جديده مع
روسيا لن تكون مثل السابقه وانها قد لا
تنتهي على الاطلاق لو سمحت اشرح لنا هذا
المفهوم الذي تتحدث عنه
اذا ما فكرنا بالحرب البارده واتحاد
السوفيتي فكانت نزاع عن ايدولوجيا عالميا
بين الشيوعيا وبين
الاساليب الحره للسياسات والاقتصاديه
كانت امبراطوريه متعدده الاوطان وما عادت
موجوده الان الحرب البارده اعتبرت على
انها انتهت رسميا عندما انهار الاتحاد
السوفيتي او اتقسم الى روسيا وجمهوريه
الاخرى هذا لن يحصل مع روسيا اليوم
وكذلك
ليست منافسه دوليه ايديولوجيه الكل يستطيع
ان يقول ابن الشيوعيه فشلت لانها ما عادت
الدوله الشيوعيه بل هي دوله روسيا ضعفت
باشكال كثيره ولكن مع ذلك كما شخص الرئيس
بوتين فهي الدوله ذات طموحات انترياليه
كما اظهره الحرب الادائيه ضد اوكرانيا
ولذلك لا ارى بان هاتين الحالتين تلك التي
كانت قبل حوالي 35 عاما والتي نراها الان
متشابها
ايضا تعتبر انه الحرب في اوكرانيا تدعم
فكره ان الديمقراطيه الامريكيه على شفا
الفشل كيف ولماذا
نحن الامريكيون يجب ان ننظر داخل حدودنا
فيما يخص الديمقراطيه معنا ان نتذكر
الاحداث التي حصلت قبل اقل من عامين عندما
كان هنالك رئيس خسر الانتخابات
واحاول ان يقوم بعمليه انقلاب المحافظه
على السلطه واستمر منذ ذلك الوقت باكاذبها
حول نتائج تلك الانتخابات
قبل ان تحاول اي حكومه امريكيه ان تلقي
المحاضرات على الديموقراطيه لاي حكم اخرى
يجب ان ننظر الى ما يحصل هنا داخل بلادنا
اما فيما يخص
مشكله الكبيره بهذا الخصوص ما تحدث عنه
يخص حول كيف بعض السياسات التي نسمعهم
السياسيين في واشنطن مواقفنا حول هذه
المساله وكذلك حول العديد من المسائل اقصد
مسائل السياسه الخارجيه هي تعكس التنافس
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي اكثر مما هي
حول
التحليلات الدقيقه لما يصب في مصلحه
امريكا او السلام العالمي كما تذكر بان
رئيس الاسبقت شامبو كان وجودا جدا مع
روسيا
اقل وديه عن اوكرانيا حينها والكثير من
ذلك
اضعف او استمر بين الحزب الجمهوريه حيث
رئيس بوتين لا يزال لديه سيطره كبيره جدا
او يحصل على دعم كبير منه اي اذا هل تتوقع
ان يكون لكل هذه التطورات تاثير على
الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه المقبله في
الولايات المتحده
المتحده
ستحدد كما تحدث في انتخاب السابق بشكل
اساسي حول المساله الاقتصاديه داخل امريكا
وتعتمد على وضعيه التضخم وسوق العمل واذا
ما كانت الولايات المتحده تتجنبوا اي ركود
اقتصادي وكل هذا تحتها السيطره البنك
المركزي او الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
وامر هذه السياسات الخارجيه ومواضيعها
فاعتقد بان اهميه ستكون اقل من مساء
الاقتصاديه وربما سيكون لها اثر اذا
الولايات المتحده ما انخرطت بشكل مباشر في
نزاع مسلح داخل الشرق الاوسط وربما على
المدى القصير سيوفر بعض الدعم السياسي لاي
وقائد او رئيس كان حينها اما على المدى
البعيد فاذا ما اكتشفنا بانه خطا ومغامر
عسكريه فسوف يخسر بعدها الدعم السياسي
ولكن العام الاساسي سيكون هو الاقتصاد
يعني كما
الانتخابات التي قبلها وتلك التي قبلها
ايضا سيد داش
البروفيسور في جامعه جورج تاون والمسؤول
السابق في وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك على المشاركه في
هذه الحلقه الف شكر
الى هنا مشاهدينا الكرام انتهت حلقه اليوم
من البعد الاخر يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك
ويوتيوب كما يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا
على العربيه بودكاست ومشاهدتها والاستماع
اليها على منصه شاهد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]